As a result of this player's history
DDoS activity, abusive behavior and poor
sportsmanship, the player behavior team
has issued a lifetime ban on Jensen.
His account has been perma banned and
all future accounts will be permabanned on site.
Jensen has consistently disregarded the letter and spirit of the Summoner's Code.
His disrespect for the
rules of the game is unacceptable for
any player, especially a high profile
eSports competitor who has a regular
opportunity to lead the community by
example.
Nikolaj Jensen has become of the West's strongest Mid laners, and players for one of the league's most iconic teams.
(Casting)
But unlike some of his contemporaries the journey he took to get there was anything but standard.
Jensen: But unfortunately we got disqualified as a
team and a few members of the team,
including me got banned due to toxic behavior.
The former World of WarCraft
arena enthusiast used the alias of Veigodx
in his early League of Legends days.
Jensen became known for his solo queue play
in Season 2, especially his 1v1 out plays.
And helped found a roster called Team
Solo Mebdi, which included players such as
Nukeduck, YamatoCannon, and Rayt3ch.
The team was set to compete in the
qualifiers for the Season Three European
Championship Series. It was the first
split of the LCS in Europe and qualification was a big deal.
Joe Miller: To earn a
spot in the qualifying rounds the teams
have had to battle their way through the
online qualifiers all placed highly in
those major tournaments throughout the
preseason.
Though competition had existed for European teams before Season 3, it was never like this.
This was a major opportunity.
Unfortunately for Jensen it
wasn't an opportunity he would get.
A competitive ruling from Riot Games
banned him from competitive play
indefinitely, and Team Solo Mebdi was
disqualified from the competition.
The Riot Games ruling said that Jensen had
consistently disregarded the letter and
spirit of the summoner's code. His
disrespect for the rules of the game is
unacceptable for any player, especially a
high profile eSports competitor who has
a regular opportunity to lead the
community by example. Riot said that
Jensen had publicly and unapologetically
admitted to engaging in a series of DDoS
attacks against high elo players. Jensen
admitted to having threatened DDoS in an
interview with in2LOL shortly
afterwards.
But said he never actually did it.
Jensen: After that I felt really down. I definitely learned a lot about myself as a person.
Not only was his Veigodx account banned,
but all future accounts belonging to
Jensen would be banned on site as well.
It was a lifetime ban in all senses of
the term. This was a big departure from
previous Riot bans where players like IWillDominate had been allowed a new
start under a different alias, which
Jensen was denied. Jensen's future as a
competitive player seemed done. Left
without any real options
Jensen found another way to leave his
mark on the competitive scene. Though the
exact date is unclear, Jensen became the
coach of SK gaming. A fact that was
discovered by fans of the competitive
scene, though it was not formally
announced at the time. The initial ruling
against Jensen had stated that he was
ineligible to compete in the LCS and in
any Riot affiliated League of Legends
tournaments indefinitely. This suspension
shall commence immediately.
Whether coaching qualified as competition was
unclear. In Korea however where worlds
was to be held that year, coaching was
already recognized and according to Riot
that meant that Jensen was banned from
being officially recognized as a coach
despite the fact that he had already
been part of SK staff if informally up
to that point. Their explanation he had
been granted access to the EU LCS studio
during Season Four as a team guest. Also,
team guests would not be allowed for Worlds.
But according to an AMA he did
in October 2014, he had previously
reached an agreement with Riot that
allowed him to play the game without the
ban on site provision. While he wasn't
allowed to compete, his new accounts
would no longer be targeted as long as he
maintained his behavior.
Riot Games banned policy underwent a big change in
late November 2014.
Instead of permanently banning players
from competitive play and issuing ban on
site orders, Riot instead changed those
bans to indefinite bans meaning that
they would be reviewable at a later date
if players' conduct on their new accounts was acceptable.
Jensen was finally
allowed to stream and his ban came up
for review under the new policy, but
according to riot he did not yet meet
the criteria to be unbanned. Still riot
said his case would be reviewable five
weeks before the beginning of the LCS
Summer Split.
The team he would eventually join, Cloud 9 had a rollercoaster Spring Split in 2015.
Hai, the team's midlaner had long acted as the primary shot-caller.
C9 managed a
second-place finish in the Spring Playoffs.
(Casting)
But Hai then step down from the
active roster citing a wrist injury.
The roster that had played together since
April 2013 had made its first major move
and Jensen was set to become the first
of a second generation of Cloud 9 players.
Jensen: After I got unbanned I was lucky
enough to get picked up by Cloud 9.
I want the best for C9 and I'll do everything I can to help support them get to where we're supposed to be.
(Casting)
Although statistically Jensen had an above-average season, it became clear that Hai had been more than
just the team's mid laner. He was a key
part of their shot calling and strategy
the team sometimes seemed lost without
him.
Relegation became a real possibility and
the team needed Hai back, but it wasn't
Jensen who would step aside,
it was the jungler Meteos.
Sneaky: I don't think, I don't know if Meteos, is like out.
But I think we're trying this.
The
change didn't instantly turn Cloud 9 around,
but putting Hai in at the jungler
position gave the team enough momentum
to avoid the promotion tournaments.
Jensen: Meteos is still a great jungler.
They have a bit of a different style where Hai
is much more supportive I would say.
But the major thing was like the shotcalling,
but also Hai used to be a mid laner so he
understands what I need and he can
like help me much more and it's easier
for him to understand when you have to help me as well.
After winning a tiebreaker against Team 8 they placed seventh in the regular season
not playoff bound, but not facing down
relegation. However C9 had earned enough
championship points to make it to the
North American Regional Gauntlet and
there the team would finally find their
stride.
(Casting)
Jensen was a key part of the team's
efforts as they reverse swept both
Gravity Gaming and Team Impulse before
winning three and one against Team
Liquid.
Jensen: Man I'm super happy right now, like I don't even realize it myself I think, but I don't know I'm just so happy right now.
Against all odds Cloud 9 had made it to worlds.
Jensen's first season with the team despite rocky team dynamics, showed flashes of brilliance.
Hai: And I'm actually pretty surprised at how
Jensen took the games, he was 0 - 2,
like aight dudes we're going in now, we're
gonna win. I was like I can appreciate
that so everyone had a very good mentaltiy for the 0 - 2.
Think about that for a moment, in Jensen's past he had grappled with controlling his emotions.
By his own admission he had been a toxic player.
Jensen: But I think I have a
lot to improve on still so I think the
main goal is to be good at good for Worlds for world so we'll see.
But during his rookie split one game away from elimination he chose a different path.
Jensen: We might start out a bit slow, but
I think by the end of the season we will
be one of the best if not the best team In NA
He chose to cheer on his teammates and it had worked.
Jensen had become the first permanently banned player to be redeemed.
Hai: I think in the
beginning of the season Jensen was a
little nervous to play had a lot of big
shoes to fill up basically and I don't
know how his team was there to help him
up that much.
At Worlds Cloud9 got off to a hot start in Group B with three straight wins. The next week they
followed that up with three losses and
then were eliminated in the tiebreaker by AHQ e-sports club.
(Casting)
The Gauntlet
and Worlds may have been a Cinderella
run for the team, but Spring 2016 broke
up much of the original Cloud 9 roster.
Hai and Balls were moved to Cloud 9
Challenger. Meteos returned as jungler and
Impact was added to the roster as the
new top laner. 2016 saw Jensen settle
into his role as C9 starting mid laner
and changed his alias from Incarnation.
He earned all pro team honors in the
Spring Split and the team 5th - 6th in
Spring Playoffs and second in Summer,
earning another trip to the Gauntlet and
yet another trip to Worlds. He also set a
new record for kills in a single game
(Casting)
While Jensen's behavior had been reformed his
signature cockiness remains.
Jensen: Yeah I would say I would say I'm pretty cocky when it comes to the game, yeah.
Thorin: And what is that based on then, just knowing you're better? Thinking you're better?
Jensen: Yeah I would say I would say it's a mix of both.
Going into Worlds 2016 Jensen expressed his intention to defeat Faker in lane on Twitter.
A now notorious comment especially given the outcome.
Jensen: If you want to prove yourself you have
to beat Faker and that's like one
opportunity I get so that's what I'm going to do.
(Casting)
The team ultimately went out in Quarterfinals that year,
and while Jensen didn't clap Faker he has shown continued improvement over his time in the NA LCS.
He was neck and neck with Bjergsen in the Spring Split, and statistically the best NA LCS Mid laner in Summer.
Ultimately Jensen showed
us that redemption is possible.
Even for those who receive some of the harshest
punishments that Riot Games has ever issued.
Not only that, but his route to
that success showed us that he may even
have become a better player and teammate
in the process.
Thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that subscribe button.